alright I'm back with my fancy new eyes
so let's talk about transformers now I
know a lot of people have taken time to
rip into these films and compare them
and yeah they suck we get it my question
is why did we expect them to be good
so why did we expect them to be any good
I want to clarify where I'm going with
this I'm not really interested in
sitting here and complaining about how
bad the new movies are or claiming that
Michael Bay's buzz Bunny it´ll sodomized
each other like a little bit you are
because I'm extreme
there's a lot of movies coming out these
days that all suffer from the same bad
scripting decisions and I'm sure I'll
get around to talking about that trend
sooner or later but for right now what
I'm interested in is a quirk that comes
up specifically with transformers more
so than a lot of other properties and
it's more than just nostalgia
but it's also nostalgia so let's talk
about that too nostalgia as a term was
coined in 1688 by yo.hannes Hoffer a
Swiss doctor to describe the kind of
homesickness reported among Swiss
mercenaries fighting in Italy in France
what they were experiencing was a form
of depression that would probably call
culture shock today as they leave their
mountainous homes for the lowland plains
of Italy in France the foreign landscape
combined with the harsh living
arrangements led many soldiers to become
despondent and fixated on the way things
were back home no real surprise there in
response to this their superior officers
banned the performance of kurai hen a
traditional Swiss melody that you're
probably pretty familiar with
through the 1700's and 1800's the
definition of a nostalgia is a specific
medical condition waned but the word
hung around is the Romantic movement of
the early 1800s latched on to the
concept they loved the poetic notion of
soldiers pining for the pastoral
simplicity of their home back in the
mountains playing their folk songs and
thus the modern concept of nostalgia was
born looking back to the past is a
better simpler time
this concept is often paired with the
notion of Goddard a meringue or the
twilight of the Gods the notion that the
present is in decline a less pure less
advanced less good version of the past
in the past gods walked among men and
there were real heroes and it was a
golden age for comics and television and
industry and philosophy and art and
everything else that I think is awesome
the cause of this perception is a bunch
of filters that the brain has in place
for how memories are stored and
retrieved in a lot of ways memory is
like a photo album you don't take a lot
of photos of funerals bad days arguments
for the crushing monotony of day-to-day
living you take photos of parties
weddings birthdays graduations and
reunions when it comes to remembering
the past we typically remember the good
parts version of it this is doubly true
with culture because we tend to forget
or marginalize the crap even if it was
incredibly popular in the moment
this is where transformers comes into
the picture looking back at the show in
the 1986 movie it's just not very good I
know that saying that on the internet
borders on treason but it's true the
story doesn't make much sense the
characters have no personality the
pacing is touch-and-go and they made
some really really weird decisions in
fact a lot of those same criticisms can
be leveled at the new films as well
there's little to distinguish one
transformer from another and they don't
so much have personalities as they just
have a role to fill that one's a sports
car this one's a dump truck that guy's a
jet it makes sense that we remember the
good parts version of the past
idealizing things that we grew up with
even remembering them as being better
than they actually were but what's the
good parts version here let me tell you
it's the toys introducing blasters it
looks like an innocent radio but
transform is the powerful Autobot
communicator
the Transformers each sold separately
from Hasbro this is the second point I
wanted to make and the one that's
specific to Transformers more so than
even the other hyper marketable cartoons
of the era like Thundercats or eman and
that self constructed narrative well a
lot of the cartoons from the early 80s
existed to sell toys few of them were
quite as shameless as transformers the
characters are basically devoid of
personality being defined more by their
look and form than anything else in a
lot of ways the Autobots and Decepticons
are ciphers or tabula rasa blank slate
there's enough information there to get
started but everything else is empty
space this goes down even into the
character design which is what sets it
apart from its peers whose characters
were generally humans or humans with
pointy ears the large blocky robot
designs are just humanoid enough for
sympathetic anthropomorphize ation and
operate only at the lowest levels of
design personality correlation and even
then just barely
you have got male deer foldable human
what the hell is simple morphic - and
through humanization alright alright
I'll slow down simple morphic and
through humanization also called
sympathetic anthropomorphize ation is
really just a big fancy phrase that
means making something look more like a
human so that the audience will project
human emotions onto it it's pretty
standard practice in animation and
there's a whole different degree from
really little things like adding more
human eyes to an otherwise
normal-looking animal like in Fox in the
Hound or completely restructuring the
face like in Finding Nemo or you could
just watch this Simpsons clip to
understand the contrast
boy look at that
the idea behind anthropomorphize ation
is that the audience has an easier time
connecting with things that look more
like themselves and this breaks out into
a hierarchy of things that we care for
we care more for our immediate family
than we do for strangers and we care
more for other mammals than we do for
reptiles and more for reptiles and birds
and more for birds than fish and more
for fish than insects basically the less
human something looks the harder it is
for us to care about it and the easier
it is to vilify it if you want your
villains to be easier to dislike then
give them reptilian or insectoid
features this is why Ursula the sea
which is half octopus the merfolk are
already fairly alien but octopuses are
even more alien in contrast this folds
into design personality correlation
which is typically expressed in the
little things like giving Jafar from
Aladdin close-set narrow eyes and harsh
angular features but giving the Sultan
round baby like features it also carries
over expectations that we bring with us
from our own associations like how
Optimus Prime being a big truck is
probably tough strong in a blue-collar
sort of down-to-earth guy on a really
simple level the rules of design
personality correlation work off our
most basic assumptions like strong
things should be big and stocky while
fast things should be small or thin and
bigger equals more powerful
in fact a couple weeks ago in brain
candy we talked about how absurdist
humor involves intentionally violating
the audience's suspension of disbelief
tis but a scratch
well suspension of disbelief also
extends directly from our assumptions
and expectations which is why the noisy
cricket for men and black is such a
successful absurdist joke we expect
small guns to be weak guns noisy cricket
actually this size power relationship is
one of the few assumptions that
transformers regularly sticks with most
of the characters share very similar
silhouettes in their humanoid form with
only the most important characters being
significantly larger than the others the
rest of the character is made up of what
they turn into and really that's about
all there is to the Transformers
personalities a rough human silhouette
bigger robots are more powerful robots
and association with whatever real-world
thing they turn into what steps in to
fill the gap is self constructed
narrative when you're playing with a toy
you project your own expectations and
assumptions onto the toy and create your
own story even if you don't consciously
plot out each character's arc and
motivations and flaws when you have an
Optimus Prime in one hand and a Megatron
in the other your brain fills in all of
the gaps you personally need in order to
create a fulfilling narrative it's not
that Michael Bay's transformers failed
to live up to the legacy and
expectations of the original shows or
movies they fail to live up to the
expectations of our imaginations stories
and characters that we'd advented while
playing with toys I mean that makes
sense nothing is really going to live up
to the world that you create in your
head granted there's a host of other
structural problems with the films but
it's pretty telling that despite the
outcry from fans they're still raking in
the cash people are seeing these films
now before I sign off with this I do
want to talk about a specific point
where the new films go off track think
back to earlier the part about Ursula
the sea witch the merfolk are already
fairly alien compared with the human
characters so they had to make them more
human by contrasting them with Ursula
who is distinctly more aliens our
ability to successfully answer form or
fight something depends heavily on what
is compared to or contrasted against in
the new films they undercut our ability
to connect with the Transformers
themselves on an emotional level by
spending the majority of the screen time
focusing on Sam Witwicky and the other
human characters as a result the
Transformers themselves I'll just fall
into a big pool of sameness even with a
weak human character to compare them to
the human is still a real human and
forms the baseline for our expectations
preventing our brains from filling in
those blank spaces that was so easy to
fill in with the toys think about other
films that pair a human character with
something functionally alien successful
ones like ET and the Iron Giant spend a
lot of time and effort crafting the
relationship to make sure that the
outsider emotes well enough on its own
that the audience will accept it as an
emotional entity even then it's still
really easy to screw up and then you
either wind up with a Wilson the
volleyball situation where half the
audience buys it and half thinks it's
stupid or you end up with something
worse my friend might have been banished